today I'm going to be talking about how
we can leverage Foundation models for
robotics uh and kind of get the best out
of both of them to start to sort of like
motivate I'm going to do a brief demo so
essentially right now we have a robot uh
this is running in New York uh like
right now and it's got a language model
that's essentially going to command what
the robot's gonna do it writes code out
and then the robot executes the code and
it's like basically we'll read my chat
and then put it on there so uh to start
I guess Mark what's uh what's your
favorite color of these bowls and what
candy would you like
so I don't know if you can see this okay
I can make it a little bigger
and then we'll see and the robot says
okay and you want some Skittles sure
so one really nice thing about language
models is essentially uh you know they
act as this like knowledge base of even
like very esoteric things like the
Skittles are tasting the rainbow and you
can see the robot actually doing it is
over here and this is the robot's view
here and I just said I'll take Reese's
and it remembers from before that I just
said which bowl is which who's it belong
to and again you get this like very kind
of abstract knowledge that tasting the
rainbow means Skittles you can also do
things like uh
and I think when we first started like
playing with language models this is
something that was like I don't know
really impressive does that I can just
say put them all in different corners
and it understands that that means that
not the same Corners it understands what
the corners are and knows what all the
candies are and it's able to like Loop
through this like this was something
that uh I don't know about a year ago
sort of like blew our mind that this is
possible
um so I think it might have missed I
think it because they're in the same
Bowl it like it put the Reese's on top
the Skittles and then did that so this
is like one area that we're sort of
trying to like fix is that sometimes
this grounding between the code or the
language model the fact that it can't
see things means that it makes sort of
simple mistakes like this and I'll talk
through sort of like why this is a big
problem in robotics and sort of like
where we're gonna go uh to fix it so
let's see what else can I do
um the
so something like put the M M's in the
center of the bowls and this is actually
like so essentially this would just like
knows that the center is you know the
middle and then let's say
okay
so something like making a line is like
also a somewhat abstract concept it
really like requires you to understand
the way that like you know geometry
works and uh and you can kind of the
code is maybe hard to see but
essentially it should output something
oh I missed the uh Reese's because I
think it's too far off the screen
um but what I wanted to do was put the
recess in the initial spot and then oh I
think it actually got the M M's in
between the Skittles so and then the
Reese's is like so far off that it's
fallen off the table but essentially
like it actually understood like what's
there and it wrote code to be able to do
some like abstract geometric reasoning
like this and it's not like you know
we've like trained this or shown it
anything this is just like falling
directly out of the language model so
um and let's say move the
hey
so something like also like move the M
Ms down like it has to understand that
like the direction of down is is like in
the negative y direction
um
and we tell that updates and it's able
to successfully move that and then
and something like move them a little
bit up requires you to not only like
understand sort of like General geometry
but also that like a little bit is not
all the way up it's partial part of the
way and let's see if move
and then we can actually like get some
sort of like memory out of this that it
remembers that before it put them here
and so to put it back is just to recall
like the last command that it did and
then execute it again
so
that essentially
um I'm going to talk through sort of
like how we've gotten to this point and
sort of some directions for that we've
been looking at to expand Beyond this to
fix some of the issues like when it
picked up the wrong thing or uh you know
didn't do the didn't do exactly what you
expected so to start I mean this is all
about Foundation models and the the main
idea here is that you take the vast
trobe of information on the internet
throw them through a Transformer
and we get performance out of it as kind
of roboticist uh the fact that we get
this like General performance without
having to like do any work or like
collect data is really kind of like
magical I think a lot of times this
takes a lot of work for us to collect
the amount of data that was just given
to us for free from here so we should
really like strive to figure out how to
use them and these capabilities are sort
of like shooting up like starting from
language models that were able to answer
trivia or explain jokes
we can also now generate images we can
answer questions about images and do
these vqa tasks and we can even like
hear audio and directly like map it
through a foundation model to get the
text out of it and the real thing is
that all of these performances like
they're great as they are and they're
like continuing to improve and improve
and to become more and more General
robot learning on the other hand has
historically sort of been in these
domains so like really kind of
constrained environments we have these
like uh easy resets so that it can
collect data like it can close this uh
these two bins so that it moves one
thing from another it's got a very like
short Horizon tasks of pick and place
it's got a kind of structured tasks and
the robots aren't really moving around
if we're doing any sort of like mobile
manipulation it's usually like at a very
limited scale so we sort of want to you
know put robots on this wave of
foundation models and see like how much
can we get for free uh without having
the robots having to experience the
world from Foundation models and so
there are some areas of natural overlap
for example like the reasoning
capabilities of language models are
super important there's like this I
guess general knowledge that's in there
that is important for a robot to act in
the world there's also a lot of semantic
knowledge of how things map to each
other what order to do things in uh
these are things that traditionally
robotics has really struggled with but
there's actually like a lot more
challenges than there really are like
areas of overlap I think in some ways
like other fields have been very quickly
revolutionized by having Foundation
models be able to solve them robotics on
the other hand has all sorts of
challenges like just general grounding
you need to know what your robot is
capable of what the environment has a
language model can't see anything just
like it's sort of like a huge gap for
for them uh interactive decision making
everything they've been trained on is
this like unsupervised is just internet
data with no interaction no making the
wrong decision making the right decision
this is like a core part of Robotics
that they basically don't have in them
there's also really on one side we're
all about like huge amounts of data on
the other side we have not only low
amounts of data but often pretty low
quality of data I mean even the the data
that we'll I'll talk about that we
collected later like it's it's all like
tell operation data it's relatively slow
it's somewhat limited so it's really
hard to get this like expert data that
we could that we got for free from the
internet essentially
vision and just general sensing
modalities are I guess slowly getting
better in Vision language models but
have traditionally also not been an area
of strength
and then finally safety is like really
important for robotics you like can't
make maybe the same mistakes that in
language we might uh might forgive you
for making so all these kind of mean
that
they're not necessarily like natural
naturally put together and there's a lot
of challenges in like open areas of
research to try to do this so to first
start I'm going to talk about how we can
ground these models in the world and in
their environment then I'll talk about
what just powered that demo this code is
policies then I'll talk about kind of
like steps forward for building
Foundation models or using Foundation
models to give new uh knowledge to uh
Robotics and then finally I'll talk
about maybe training Our Own Foundation
model and what what that sort of looks
like
so as I said before a robot can't see or
a language model can't see so we sort of
imagine this this task that like you're
a language model and you open your eyes
uh or you can't open your eyes and
you're trying to reason over the entire
environment
um once you open it and you realize that
I've asked you I've said I've spilled my
drink can you help you realize that
what's in the scene
or things like a spilled drink a sponge
which might be able to help and also
I've got a lot of experience in the
world of doing different things so as we
sort of like go through we see you know
everything that's like where I might
want to throw that away what the gripper
looks like in the embodiment and then
also like in the in the past I've been
able to do things like pick up these
objects so this is all like crucial to
the embodiment it's both what you can do
and it's what's in the environment and
we basically want to like bring this
into a language model give it in some
ways the hands and eyes necessary to
make it do these tasks
but if we just take a language model out
of the box and say you know ask it this
question it answers pretty reasonably I
mean it says like you could try using a
vacuum cleaner or calling a cleaner it
even like takes credit for the spill
which is like a very reasonable thing
from a language model side but not
necessarily actionable for robotics
so one of the issues is like these are
again not actionable so how do we get
the language model to speak in a way
that robots can actually do it given
their embodiment
and yeah so you know we wanted to be
able to speak this language of robots we
wanted to be able to like actually be
executable and so the first algorithm
that I'll kind of put forth is uh called
say can and the idea is essentially
instead of letting the language model
where normally it would just generate
sort of like the max probability next
token we are instead going to fix the
way that it can respond so these are
like the only ways that that it can
possibly respond to it's called like a
scoring mode and basically See How
likely is it to respond in each of these
ways so I said like put the apple on the
table
and we say like these are the things you
can do you can like find an Apple find a
sponge pick up an apple
um and these are like actual
probabilities that would come out of a
language model uh and you can see like
pick up the apple is really high so like
that makes a lot of sense but if you
then like open your eyes uh you see that
well there's not an apple in front of me
I'm just sort of like in the middle of
the environment so how do we like bridge
this Gap and one way we can do this is
robotic policies usually come with
trained value functions and these value
functions are the probability of getting
the reward of succeeding at a task given
the state given the image of the
environment so here we might see that
the value functions say well
picking up an apple is like pretty low
because there's not an apple there
um putting the Apple down is extremely
low because you don't have an apple in
front of you but things that I could do
is go navigate to places this has a
higher value the like chance of getting
this reward is someone high and this
actually is basically
on one side a probability that the task
is useful so like this like low level
skill is useful to this high level task
and on the other side it's the
probability that you can actually
succeed at that given the current state
of your environment and given the
robot's abilities so together we
essentially have two probabilities one
that it's uh one that it's useful one
that is possible and together if you
multiply these we get like the most
useful and possible thing so in this
case it becomes find an Apple which you
know makes a lot of sense first you need
to identify it so once you do that you
can then update this prompt that's going
into the language model here and so now
it knows okay I found an apple the value
function gets updated saying there's an
apple in front of it and so probably it
picks uh pick up the Apple
this is uh so I mean really the
intuition here is like given this query
on one side we have what's useful to do
the overall task what knowledge comes
from a language model on the other side
what's possible in the environment given
the robotics
abilities and its knowledge
and what's really nice is we have this
like interpretable way of looking at its
decision making we can actually see that
um you know the language model is
reasoning over this the affordances are
reason over this we can see how it comes
to its decision and we can actually like
which makes it like super easy to debug
and understand but here if I said like I
suppose a code can you bring a
replacement do you actually notice that
like
it's it's kind of like picked up on the
idea of a replacement rather than like
before I said like I spilled my coat can
you bring me something to help and it
went for a sponge here it understands
that replacement means the replacement
for the coke it understands this sort of
like uh deep information and then the
affordances tell it that what it can do
is find a Coke it can't pick one up and
it slowly can make these decisions
throughout so we have this like really
nice sort of like interpretable
framework and we can uh I think we did
like 70 of our tasks though I think with
a better language model we got this up
to like 85 so one thing that's really
nice is we can basically just swap out
the language model and put in a new one
as things get better and better uh and
the other part that's really I think
important is that this grounding here
have the errors that you make so
essentially like robotics actually has
something to bring to the table this
like experience in the environment is
crucial for the language model to be
able to successfully plan and command
the robot to what to do
and a quick video of this like in action
we type some command I think this is
like I spilled a Coke and bring me a
replacement and something to clean up
though maybe the internet's cutting out
too much
and as I was saying like we'll see uh on
the right side that it pops up with the
actual like decision making process so
we can you know as it goes understand
what it's trying to do why it's trying
to do it it's all you know in language
so you can actually understand it rather
than some like actions or something more
difficult to really like grasp what's
happening
um and I'll skip forward in the interest
of time but essentially it effectively I
think
yeah we essentially asked her to do two
things we asked it to both like find
like throw away the Coke can and also
bring me something to clean up and it's
able to like put these both together to
form this like longer rise and task and
do a do a task that takes like a couple
minutes to roll out and it's like truly
long Horizon and sequential
but so one issue that arises with this
is I just like had it so that I
enumerated these very these skills and I
like scored over these skills but if you
go into like a world like this
uh it's pretty computationally
intractable for me to like write down
everything I can do there's like
pairwise things like I can stack
something on something else and so say
cam doesn't really like scale to this
like complexity this like intra this
intractability of the real world so how
do we kind of go from this idea of how
we ground uh and value functions to a
more complicated world like this
and uh the idea here in this work
grounded decoding that uh Wen long
actually uh put together is that
essentially we can instead of picking
specific scoring things just like very
uh specific Primitives we can instead
just bias it at the token level so a
language model is always uh predicting
probabilities over the next token we can
also do this with a policy we can have
that policy conditioned on some
arbitrary amount of natural language so
just like put the and then the uh the
next thing the next object has to have a
high probability uh in this scene so we
see that like the Pepsi is pretty high
the cake is also there I think these are
like little Cakes as well as like
certain letters are visible and
essentially we have this like token
level uh grounding of what's possible
and what's useful so this means that we
can also include things like safety and
preferences of the user and be able to
decode in like a much more varied like
combinatorially complex world
and we can do things like uh pack a
picnic box and ignore things like the
knife that maybe the robot's not capable
of doing because the safety function can
sort of like biases away from it and so
it's just like it's a very general way
to sort of like ground the language
model in the world and the capabilities
of the robot without losing the
expressibility of the language model
we can also use it for navigation so
choosing like where to navigate and even
the language model can trigger when it
should be grounded and when not so this
is in a way like a tool use out of the
language model we see that uh given that
we wanted uh some object
you say I'll go find and then when it
gets to the object it doesn't know
what's in the world and so it can
actually like trigger that I need to
ground this next statement and it can
look based in the world in this case
using clip what have I seen in the past
and realized that like a Pepsi can was
there or and apple was there and then
make its decision based on that so I
think the fact that this is like this
grounding is like a tool that a language
model can call up when necessary means
that you can really leverage it for very
varied tasks uh one thing that still
goes wrong though is let's say
um and we saw it in the uh in the
initial demo it failed at a task but it
didn't get any feedback that hey I
failed at that task it just failed that
and then kept going on to the next one
and in the world in the world we might
like get this like you're trying to
unlock a door and you realize you put
the key in and it didn't work so I need
to switch to a different one okay I
turned that and now it opened a language
model isn't necessarily getting this
feedback in these earlier uh in these
earlier setups so what we need is to
have some like inner monologue thinking
of okay I tried this did that succeed
what do I see in the world and there's a
lot of sorts of feedback that we can
provide we can use object recognition to
tell the language model what's available
we can use success detection to say what
uh whether it's exceeded at something
and basically build this all
into a real prompt so we get some query
like bring me a drink from the table we
use say can to determine the next task
and then we go to the table but the
language model doesn't actually know
what's at the table yet and so in say
can it's going to reason over all the
possible objects but without knowing
what's there it's very hard to sort of
like blindly reason what possibly could
be there and it said the object
recognition can just write this
description into the prompt and then
it's very clear uh you know what should
be done next
the robot can also ask questions and
basically in this inner model I realizes
like an underspecified problem I should
ask the user something and then when it
tries to do something like pick up the
Coke and it fails it can even recognize
that it failed and just try this again
so what it looks like in the real world
is that we have all these sources of
feedback and we can just build them all
into a prompt and let the language model
essentially handle this monologue of
what's going on in its head of okay I
tried this that failed what should I do
next should I uh
I think in this case we have it uh try
something and it fails because we like
explicitly stopped it from working so
picking up a Coke can and then
but now the coke can's not there anymore
so the bring me a soda maybe doesn't
work so well so maybe I should go back
to the user and ask hey uh you know this
didn't work I don't see a Coke can
anymore what would you like instead so I
see like in orange soda and it says
there's this this and we say no that
doesn't work for us so it goes back to
the planning stage and says okay now I
need to find this lime soda that we
asked for instead
so this allows the language model to be
much more ground in the world by using
these additional tools of a success
detector of human feedback of a scene
descriptor
and in this case it successfully
delivers it to the person
another nice thing that we see is that
it can even it actually like terminates
the end it says like okay I've
accomplished a task and the last thing
that it does is and this is like our you
position but it'll even like raise the
thing saying like okay I've like
completed the task
but there are some limits of What
language can do uh there's
you know I talked about putting things
in a line
um but like this would be kind of hard
to specify exactly how to do in language
it's not necessarily like the best
format also if you wanted to uh describe
the scene and language here you would
have to describe like the complexities
they're all bunched together and the
green one's a little higher than this
and the blue ones here and so language
isn't necessarily the best thing for
this also this one where we have to wait
until we see something to make another
decision
this uh feels a lot more like how kind
of code works and actually code is this
like linguistic representation of
actions it's it's uh
it's directly what we're running on the
robot at the lowest level and it has all
this power to do uh to call external
methods to do any sort of computation do
if loops and while loops and this like
more complex reasoning we see things
like put things in a line works pretty
like straightforward when you're writing
it in code even though it might be a
little bit more difficult to enumerate
in language
and most importantly there is a like ton
of data of what this is like it's sort
of the equivalent uh I mean even I think
like the best like gbt models now start
code training on code and then are
fine-tuned um like instruction following
and language so code is like this really
nice structured and we know it runs
otherwise it wouldn't be there so
there's like a a good signal that it's
high quality so it's actually like a
really good fit and it's what we run on
robots
so we should just use these language
models to write code and essentially uh
run that directly on the robot what's
kind of nice is we can both use apis so
may we have like perception apis that
can like detect where things are we can
use for Loops out of this and we can
even use the language model to write new
apis so if it generates something like
is empty or stack objects as a function
it can realize actually these weren't
already defined and then just generate
the next uh the next thing so this
hierarchical code generation actually uh
does extremely well to sort of like do
much more abstract and complicated
reasoning and it does it all pretty much
I guess few shot but without any sort of
training
so they've also looked at like every
textbook that you've seen so it can do
it can write a full controller for
something as simple as a cart poll uh it
can uh
do it can understand emojis different
languages all this sort of like falls
out for free it can even use different
Cross embodiments or different
embodiments based on the available
action so here we just list like move up
move right move back is something versus
turn left move forward so this is the
way that the robot moves and then the
code is made is able to immediately
adapt to that to be able to do new
things so it's like really showing this
power of uh I guess what prompting can
do and especially when you're prompting
in a language that's directly accessible
by the robot
and we put this on like
I guess
two three robots here with different end
effectors and like the best thing is
like you could I guess like I really
like these ones where you're like
drawing shapes because I think this
would be like an extremely complicated
control problem but in code it's
extremely trivial to just write how to
do it and you can just put it on and uh
like within a day have this running and
it can run like fairly robustly you can
also do very abstract reasoning like
make this Square bigger move something
uh to the side or write these like while
loops and if Loops that that wait for
things to happen before it makes a
decision so it's a very like I guess
powerful concept
but there's also you know some
limitations of how well we can write
things through code there's a reason why
sometimes we want these end-to-end
policies something like going to grasp a
mug might be very difficult to
effectively write through code
um so instead what we wanted to do was
basically what if we just collect a
bunch of data Maybe not quite to the
scale of foundation models but as much
as we sort of could and see what if we
just like train a model to Output
actions directly
so this is a paper called robotics
Transformer or rt1 and the idea was
basically like a simple
Transformer architecture with a few
things to make it efficient enough to
run quickly on a robot we tokenized the
whole input the instruction the image
and we put it through a couple like
efficient layers and then we go through
a Transformer and then we just directly
output tokenized output
we collected 130 000 episodes uh each
episode is maybe like 10 seconds long
over 13 robots a year and a half and a
700 tasks to be able to get it to decent
performance and and actually like it it
does pretty well so across the scene
tasks that we have it achieves 97 I
think so it's pretty near perfect except
like little mistakes here and there and
these are
scenes like this where we're randomizing
which objects are there and where the
objects are but it can also actually do
pretty well uh with unseen objects with
unseen tasks like adding in a lot more
objects and like really cluttering up
the space here and like progressively
making it more cluttered changing the
background to be you know is almost
exclusively the data came from this
scene where it's this like gray tabletop
but we put in this white tabletop with a
with a uh would would uh
cabinets and have or wood drawers and it
like is able to still open the drawers
and able to pick things up and it does a
lot better than any of these other sort
of like
um other other approaches so we tried
like just uh regular behavioral cloning
without a Transformer we tried gato
which has like some subtle differences
and found that in general rt1 actually
works pretty well and most excitingly
starts to generalize across things but I
think the the things that like they were
most excited about are its ability to
ingest uh heterogeneous data so we
collected again a ton of episodes on
this robot in this scene and then
we put in simulated data which is very
easy to collect and we put in data from
a different robot from a Kuka that was
collected for a completely different
project and we just kind of like made
the action space the same and then threw
it in and what you see is first the Sim
data if we hold out certain objects it's
only seen in Sim it makes a massive
difference I mean I think we get yeah
like it went from like 10 success or 20
success to 85 so like 65 more it's able
to even like do new skills with those
objects that it hasn't seen before in
either one so it sort of like can cross
domain transfer and then adding in these
new objects with a different robot also
works pretty well and we're able to
suddenly pick those up so we're actually
like starting to see this like scaling
um we do see that it like overfits
pretty quickly on the environment that
we have I think we had like 97 there and
like 80 in the next scene which is great
for robotics but maybe not the the level
performance that we hope to see
but it can
ingest this heterogeneous data which I
feel like that's like the real like Crux
of what a foundation model needs to be
able to do is pull in data from all
these different environments so it's
sort of it's starting to feel like oh
maybe we can train a foundation model
but some of the the big issues that we
come up come across with is so we fixed
essentially the data are we slowly lower
the data size and we lowered it by
either uniformly taking out data across
all tasks or cutting out like the lowest
data performing tasks so here we lose I
think like five percent of data but
across like the tasks that are
underrepresented but like the more
diverse tasks and we see the performance
drops really quickly if we just pull out
data kind of uniformly across the board
and keep our our diversity up we
actually see that like our performance
doesn't go down or at least not nearly
as quickly so really like diversity is
the key to this but diversity is sort of
hard to get especially for robotics you
need to have them in a lot of different
scenes
you need to yeah like and and also like
scaling up in the one scene so we have
this like classroom where we just
collect most our data it's kind of like
a waste of time at some point that
you've collected so much data in there
so we're sort of one of the big things
we're looking at is how can we like vary
this data collection
um but the performance so one way we can
data vary this data collection is that
we can imagine that we were in different
scenes so maybe we've collected some
data here
let's use diffusion models to imagine
something different this is kind of
essentially what we've done here is we
recognize which areas we've seen and
then we vary everything else that isn't
important to this task so it's picking
up the Coke can but it's imagining that
it's in a kitchen it's imagining that
it's in a living room in an office
and all this becomes useful data for the
robot and essentially we've just used
these massive diffusion models to be
able to inject new imagined experience
for the robot and give it this ability
to die to to handle diversity the way
that it works is we localize areas that
are important for the task and
everything else becomes an area that we
in paint which means we replace it with
imagined experience in this case from
the Imogen model which is like a
Foundation model for image generation
and then we throw that in as though that
was real robot experience and we see
after this pay after this one I think I
have like actual numbers but another
sort of like trippy video of
we can replace even the thing that it
was picking up so that it learns a new
task so it can learn to you know pick up
these objects while also varying
everything else in the scene or not
varying everything else in the scene
keeping the rest of the scene the same
and making sure that we're sort of like
in domain for the parts that we care
about
and you end up with this policy that is
oh yeah and like we can act as though
the whole time it picked up like a cloth
or things that are deformable
um and we see that we actually like
are able to do this at a higher rate I
think there's a lot of numbers here but
the the main thing is when we use Rosie
on all the bolded numbers are when we
added in this imagine experience it's
sort of like across the board it helps
and it doesn't really hurt anything so
it's sort of getting like this free
experience just from the the foundation
model
but I think what we really want to do is
at like the lowest levels use the
knowledge containment Foundation models
for robotics so the next thing we try to
do is actually like train our own and we
called it palmy which starts with palm
which is this like massive uh language
model from Google and vit which is a
massive Vision model from Google we put
them together and we put a bunch of all
the internet data's in there but we also
put in a bunch of Robotics data and
specific data that is like more useful
for robotics tasks so we put this onto
this like massive mixture
and then we tried it on a bunch of
different tasks and suddenly not only
can we do vqa tasks but we can do task
and motion planning we can manipulate
things in an environment and we can do
real tasks in generalize pretty well so
the the way that it works is given some
language model that's taking in a bunch
of text tokens
we also train the vit to Output
essentially like text tokens or
something like co-embedding space
between the two and
it can be images it can be anything else
but you can see essentially the language
one I was just reading in these tokens
as though they're all text tokens and
these other smaller models are
outputting things that then go in as
Vision tokens or object tokens or things
like that and we train the whole thing
end to end so that it learns to
essentially like recognize the text
tokens and the image tokens as though
they're all the same thing
and not only are we able to do sort of
eqa tasks like and kind of complicated
ones like given this image what's in
there and answering emojis or
something like really simple like just
describe this image but we can also do
mold manipulations so we can do say can
but all just like in a single model we
can do task and motion planning and have
an output a real plan to do somewhat
complex uh sequential reasoning or
tabletop manipulation then we we also
did just like language only tasking not
even with vision and because we started
with this language model we don't lose
any of the initial language reasoning
capabilities so it can do math or write
haikus or
you know it's a very like General Swatch
of things
one of the most exciting things though
is that we really see positive transfer
here so if we train on only like on the
same model but only with this data and
only this data and only this data
we get sort of like middling performance
but if we put them all together and we
put in all the like internet scale data
all of them shoot up massively so we we
see that they're basically like there's
reasons to throw everything sort of like
into one pile and it's and even though
these are like pretty different visually
especially the uh like between this like
language table and this and the say can
data they're extremely like diverse
visuals the action space is different
and it's still able to actually like
cross domain transfer
we also see that as we get to larger and
larger models the performance doesn't go
down as much when we add in this Vision
so essentially these are just language
only tasks and with an 8 billion
parameter Palm model this is what it
started with for performance and when we
added in this like training it dropped
like massively like it basically is a
terrible language model at this point if
we go to a bigger model it drops a
little less and then as we get to the
really large one it essentially does the
same and even on some tasks it got
better so we see that like if you get to
a really large model it's able to ingest
all this information without actually
forgetting or like having any
catastrophic forgetting of its previous
knowledge this is like extremely
promising that maybe we don't lose too
much by by doing this
some uh
some examples that I think we were
pretty excited about or just thought
were kind of fun a visual reasoning are
here so it's able to do things like read
off here uh
the price of these items and then do
math based on that to tell you how much
it would cost to
um to get two custom pizzas we're able
to I think like this one is particularly
complex reasoning because it's a mix of
like words and rules and so it's it's
saying you can't enter unless it's a
bike but it has to understand that like
it's saying except but then there's also
a picture of a bike and emergency
vehicles and it's able to reason through
this to recognize that like on a bike
it's okay to go through
we can also use multiple images so we
can compare I think and these are like
definitely not in the training set this
is like one of us went to I think like
Marine layer and took some pictures and
said what's the difference between these
two images
um what matches and it's able to like
put this complex reasoning to work even
over these like images that it's never
seen before which is like very exciting
especially for robotics tasks
and then we're able to put it on robots
so they said so we can use it to on the
same model do these tasks on the right
and and neither of these is it putting
it's not putting out actions but it's
commanding a low-level policy that's
putting out actions but it's able to
handle adversarial disturbances like
here we like block it from picking
something up it's able to close the loop
with the environment and
repeatedly you know recognize what it's
done what it needs to do as we
manipulate the environment it can
recover to it and it can do this all
through the same checkpoint so you feel
like this is a real step towards doing
this uh kind of multi-embodiment brain
that the is this Foundation model for
robotics
so this is kind of my last slide but uh
what's next is we want to go beyond
language we want to continue pushing on
this like visual language uh domain
but we also recognize that there's a lot
of issues with applying foundation
models to robotics they're really like
not
um
perfectly mated for each other which I
think is like a robotics researcher is
kind of exciting that there's a lot of
areas to still figure out
uh but in the areas that we can leverage
them we should sort of Leverage them as
best we can and do so in like in a way
that makes sense for robotics so things
like grounding them in the scene uh
recognizing constraints or using value
functions and sources of information
that we already had for robotics like uh
and then but I think like really at the
end of the day like what we need to
improve are the robotic side of things
we need to
while language models continue to
increase in performance and vision
language models the interaction side of
Robotics is still definitely like the
bottleneck of the overall system
but we do think that like we can kind of
move there's a lot of really positive
signs that like an embodied Foundation
models possible this positive transfer
across things this um
this ability to ingest heterogeneous
data between different robots from SIM
is extremely promising and the fact that
we don't get catastrophic forgetting as
we train these models with more robotics
data means that we can kind of Leverage
everything that was there but still add
in our own data
so I think there's a lot of people who
worked on this
most of which are pictured here but not
all
um
but yeah I think that's that's it so I
think I I can obviously take questions
and then we also have the robot running
in the back end if there's like anything
we want to try on that but
uh I just had a quick question when you
were measuring the success rate
um you mentioned that you had like
safety precautions to make sure that
there wasn't any catastrophic failures
like you would find my maybe the
language model like you said that you
would forgive but
um what was like the range of failures
is there anything that didn't like
perfectly accomplish the task or is
there anything where the robot did
something that was actually like you
know left the place worse than it
started
so yeah I mean certainly like sometimes
it like picks something up and knocks it
off the table and then uh in a way
that's like worse I think our policies
are trained to uh like terminate or have
failure if they like hit something like
the table too hard or things that mostly
like could cause any sort of damage so
those are sort of like both baked into
the robotic stack and then also trained
into the policy that that's like that
that would be a negative outcome
um so there weren't anything that was
like
too terrible generally though the the
errors I feel like were split pretty
evenly between the robotics policy
failing and the language model doing the
wrong reasoning for what's in the scene
it was sort of like 50 50 whether it
came from one or the other but I think
as like language models continue to get
better like it probably if we went back
and like re-benchmark this with like
this was we'd probably read this a year
ago
and if we did a language model now I
think it would be more on the robotic
side than on the language model side
thank you
more questions
uh yeah a few questions from uh the zoom
room Ken asked what about monitoring
force feedback teller operation to teach
or learn about Force interactions
so uh I feel like maybe I need more
context on exactly what that means but I
think like
um
I mean a lot of the data that we've
collected here is through teleoperation
but it's always with a or maybe it's
about like improving teleporation but
right now it's with an Oculus controller
that's like tied to what the hand is and
honestly it like our tele operation is
pretty basic and really I mean I've
tried to like pick things up but then
it's like hard to do so I think things
like adding in haptic feedback would be
incredibly impactful I think I mean we
see things like uh the like recent like
Aloha paper uh where it's like just a
much better controller and it seems like
dexterous manipulation is much easier so
I think this is like a huge area that
there's
sort of poor performance from tele
operation that's limiting our expert
data which is then limiting our policies
maybe maybe as a follow-up a lot of the
tasks that you show are Vision based in
robotics you have lots of other sensors
that are anything you could say about
what your thoughts are on on you know
this applied our IMU whatever yeah I
mean I think there's a lot of tasks that
like not having depth in there is and
not having torque sensing is probably
like a little bit limiting I think the
fact that I guess the way we think about
it is we're trying to push as far as we
can in the simplest domain to see how
what level of performance we can get if
we were like a product trying to get to
the best one we might be able we might
add these in but the fact that we can
get to 97 on all these tasks this is
like moving objects opening drawers
putting things into things flipping
things over knocking a can over that
like the haptics you'd think would be
important but we can still actually get
to 97 through learning so there's
you can get pretty far with images and
since they're available the kind of
across the board we want to take like
the simplest approach but I do think
probably closing that last three percent
is maybe on adding in extra forms of
supervision like that
cool Final question from uh the chat uh
us
curious if it's possible for many of
these models to run on consumer hardware
for smaller robots like an Nvidia Jetson
or something 550 billion parameters not
going to be practical for Hardware of
this diet so curious what the options
are for improvement yeah I mean I think
there's a lot of areas around like
distilling policies that seem to be
relatively promising
um I also think like the fact that these
are hosts in the cloud and there's
somewhat minimal latency like the we can
run a lot of these at like you know
under one Hertz and sometimes like five
Hertz means that maybe the uh maybe the
Jetson doesn't need to have the model
running on it is probably like the the
real answer that it's not as
crucial as maybe we expect there's
probably some like really high frequency
things and then there's ways to to speed
them up but for now uh the cloud seems
to work pretty well
thank you can you elaborate more on how
you're using tele operate data for
training uh for image and text you don't
need that are you training the
trajectory of those using it hello yeah
so essentially each
so the the four architecture looks like
we just take the last six images
and then output the next action that the
person took so if they have like some
trajectory we're chunking this up into
single time steps where we just predict
the very next action to take given those
like last six images
I see so there is someone controlling
that arm yeah so to get the data we
essentially like someone takes a uh
Oculus controller and moves as though
they're going to pick it up they can
also do like a handheld controller which
moves the robot hand to then like grasp
the object we then take all that
demonstration data and turn it into
single time steps where we take an image
and we output an action I see I see
thank you
dude
uh thank you Brian for the talk it was
very great
um you mentioned that rt1 outputs
actions directly whereas like palmy
outputs like decisions at a low level
controller executes I guess like going
forward uh which of these like two
approaches do you think is more reliable
and I'm also curious like how reliable
is the low level controller that palmy
uses to execute actions yeah so the logo
controller that palmy uses XU action is
actually rt1 so it's like relatively
reliable as long as it's in like the
scenes that it's been in but we do see
like good generalization but maybe not
perfect generalization
um in terms of like
right now I think the reason why we
split it this way is that most like the
internet data that the language model
has been trained on is at that like
higher level like there isn't action
data or things like that that are in the
internet I think going forward though
we're definitely like pushing in this
direction of what levels can we train
into these models and still get pretty
high performance and I think it's
somewhat of an open question of where
where do you get better performance
maybe the language model or the vision
language model does much better
generalization so potentially it's it's
you need to find like the sweet spot and
trade-offs between performance and
generalization across the two so I think
like the the small local model is
probably higher performance and the
other one has higher generalization
um is like the answer
got it and I guess a quick whole
follow-up to that is for most of the
failures you're observing uh is it at
like the low level controller level or
is that like the uh llm or BLM level
yeah so I
think the the high level making a
mistake or the low level making mistake
now I think if you do like palmy or
something like this it's much more on
the low level making mistakes like it's
probably like 80 20 now
um and uh yeah the performance of
foundation models improving has
certainly
puts her robotics in the in the lower
position of performance like the the
errors are on our sack
thank you so much
thank you again oh you have one
just out of curiosity now that we have
you here and have the robot running what
happens if you if you ask it to do stuff
with objects that are not actually in
the scene does it does it throw an error
or does it try something weird so I
think because it's on code it probably
won't do much but uh we can like
what would you like
Apple
let's see
it says I don't have an apple
so I mean it does have like this list of
objects that are uh
coded in for it to look for
and I guess not on the list and then
that goes to the object Hector and so
the language model I've never I haven't
tried that before but yeah it doesn't
and you can actually I mean it's
unfortunately I can't like increase the
size of this but it's like all the code
that that gets actually run into it in
this case like the language model just
took it like it just responded without
writing without writing any code
all right thank you again thanks
[Applause]